it's pretty safe to say that the world
is eager to revisit Star Wars Disney
also wants to take another look at rogue
one but not in the same way according to
a report from page six the studio isn't
happy with what it's seen in his ass
director Gareth Edwards for reshoots
looks like the rebels might be in more
trouble than we thought an anonymous
source at the studio said the filmmaking
team in the studio always anticipated
additional shooting and second unit work
to make the film the absolute best it
can be and the actors were aware that
there would be additional shooting
coming off the force awakens there's an
incredibly high bar for this movie and
we have a responsibility to the
franchise and to the fans to deliver the
best possible movie we can Star Wars
wrote one is slated to release on
December 16th of this year as of now the
movie should still hit that December
premiere date films reshoot all the time
so this isn't a crazy request from
Disney but for all the important Star
Wars news you already in the right place